old VW buses like the t2 have legions of
fans the last one rolled off production
lines in Germany in 1979 but in Sao
Paulo Brazil production of the t2
continued right up until the end of last
year it was a huge success during its
lifetime for a whopping 56 years an
average of 20,000 rolled off the
assembly line every year now it's the
end of an era the van got all dressed up
for its swan song with a limited edition
model at Volkswagen sales directly
Oakland funk says the old gal is a very
specific product some Brazilians regard
the VW as a Brazilian brand of German
descent they feel closely tied to both
the beetle and the van goddamn kfo
danpalm VI never Zonda Lafitte wooden
hide
at first VW's had to be imported to
Brazil but in 1957 a plant in a yeta
began building the t2s predecessor 51
demand grew rapidly from just 370 sold
in the first year to over 41,000 four
years later production of the t2 began
in 1975 signaling the start of a success
story that lasted for almost four
decades without changing the Vans basic
character VW constantly optimized the
vehicle
the limited last edition model was
originally envisioned as a batch of just
600 but the man was so great that VW
doubled that to 1,200
mauricio gusto marks is the proud owner
of one of the first VW vans ever built
as someone khumba moon of Saint
cincuenta
he says is is a 1950 panel valdon 20 me
he found it abandoned in the favelas and
spent a year and a half restoring the
vehicle with original parts he replaced
the headlights and the engine he says
there are only four 1950 panel vans in
Brazil and only 36 of them in the whole
world in Brazil the van is a Volkswagen
and the literal sense at some real
people's car the multi-purpose vehicle
can still be seen on almost every street
corner there are no limits to the
inventive spirit with which people
modify it the t2 is often seen with the
most wacky modifications it can be a
police car a fire truck a mobile snack
bar a TV broadcasting studio or an
ambulance
the VW van is good for just about
everything everyone loved this
jack-of-all-trades but it wasn't able to
keep up with the times
stricter safety and emission regulations
helped kill off the cult classic
I so far the often Funke explains that
the van was designed more than 60 years
ago when airbags and advanced braking
systems didn't exist even the best
engineers can't fit these upgrades into
a VW bus so now regulations mean that
the company had to end production
despite continuing high demand existed
the final last edition model number 1200
was never put up for sale it was
carefully packed up and sent by
freighter home to Wolfsburg Germany
a special place was waiting for it at
the Volkswagen Auto Museum
here the t2 enjoys its retirement among
its relatives
when Oliver Koon head of the museum's
vintage car team is sad that this
perennial icon is no longer being
manufactured he's glad that the last of
the species is in his own hands but says
that is meagre consolation exploit oh
all right wins for the three dozen
states over here state our ideas my
knock light at art always women as
fathers never taught it the t2 is going
nowhere soon with such a loyal following
plenty of existing ones won't be junked
or retired for a long time to come